[Music]
hello welcome to dear Hank and John
there is that pretty good dear children
Hank the comedy podcast about death
where me and my brother John we answer
your questions give you d be suffice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John
hi hi how are ya you know that part in
Rushmore actually you don't cuz you're
not familiar with Rushmore I can't
believe you haven't seen Rushmore at
least twelve times how can you even
claim to be my brother anyway there's
this part in Rushmore where one of the
characters says I ain't even here
sergeant I'm in Cheyenne Wyoming that's
how I am I'm not I'm not really here to
be honest with you I'm in Cheyenne
Wyoming I'm just like I'm working a lot
and I am in grossed in my work and I am
not really capable of thinking about
anything else how are you good how do I
get you here I need a I need a brother
no I have to stay in Cheyenne
unfortunately I have to stay in Cheyenne
Wyoming as long as possible because it
is the closest that I really ever come
to pure happiness or actually it's not
like happiness but pure like fulfillment
or engagement or whatever like you know
how you spend your whole entire life
like stuck inside of the the prison of
yourself and there's no escaping it and
it's sort of like a horror movie in that
like you live inside of a consciousness
trying to make me uncomfortable with the
prison of my body John I wanted not
recognize I don't want to don't want to
think about it you know I ya know and
lots of people lots of people are able
to very successfully not think about it
and I actually think that is the correct
strategy so we can just move on to the
short poem if you'd like uh well first I
have to say that I got a comb on an
airplane and it's falling apart in my
hands and I'm like why do they even give
me this terrible comb why do they make
it out of something that can't it's
incapable of holding its comb enos
second I have to say John how are you
feeling about pod con
I'm very excited about pod comm but if
we can briefly return to the issue of
your comb I just want to note Hank that
there are first world problems and then
there are the free comb I got for
sitting in business class on an
international flight did not live up to
my expectations problems because I know
a lot about air travel and so I know how
you get those free combs and if you ever
complain about that again I'm disowning
you yeah I guess I was complaining about
it I've just I've had it for a while and
I've been using it and and I guess I've
been fidgeting with it too much and now
now it's missing a number of times well
life is hard and full of disappointments
I'm very excited for pod con for those
of you who don't know there is a a
podcast conference coming up planned by
my brother Hank and some other people
it's in Seattle and it's gonna be lots
of fun I'm gonna be there tons and tons
and tons of people are gonna be there
yeah we have I decided to reach out to
two of my friends in the podcasting
world
Travis McElroy and and Joseph Inc of
welcome to night Vale and and they were
like yeah yeah that is the thing that
should exist and then we got together
with the rest of their teams and with
the rest of my team who's here on this
podcast with me right now
and we're doing an IndieGoGo campaign
for it and it's going well yeah you
could you can attend remotely if you
don't if you don't want to travel to
Seattle and or can't travel to Seattle
but you can also attend in real life
with your physical body in Seattle and
it'll be just like listening to podcasts
only you know like instead of spending
the time that you listen to podcasts in
that sort of like nonsense Oriole place
where audio can take you you'll have to
be with your physical body in a room
with a bunch of other people with bodies
so I mean upsides besides downsides
there will be many amazing and weird
things happening but for for remote
backers will be sending out all of the
stuff that happens in audio form but for
the people who are gonna be there in the
real life it is nice to do things with
your real physical body right yes
absolutely physical body unfortunately
even though there's no choice it hurts
sometimes you do have no choice that is
that is a bit
it's a bit of a you know I don't like
this isn't it nice sometimes to not have
a choice cuz I hate choices oh so I
would like if it was like what body do
you want to be in this morning that
sounds like a lot of work like stress I
have to think about that now right hard
enough picking pants yeah no I for me
the ideal situation would be if it was
like do you want to be in a body today
and I'd be like nay just nobody at all
yeah now I'm gonna take I'm gonna take
the pleasures of the senses and just get
rid of them completely that's not true
you're right no it's much more
complicated than that can I read your
short poem okay sure
everything is more complicated than you
want to make it nothing fits on a bumper
sticker
so we got a short poem suggestion from
Krystal she wanted me to read a poem by
rupee cow or so I'm going to this one is
very short I am water soft enough to
offer life tough enough to drown it away
just a good short poem hmm good short
poem about water toughness and softness
you know I did think for a tiny bit that
the poem the or reading was about what
can and cannot fit on a bumper sticker
and I was like oh that one was
interesting mm-hmm I guess actually
that's a pretty good poem as poems that
fit on bumper stickers go that was a
pretty good one hey should we answer
some questions from our listeners oh
sure let's do that this one is from
grace I thought that it was interesting
because grace has a pretty cool job but
is also worried about it dear Hank and
John I'm about to complete my first year
working in a somewhat and well-known
online web site covering politics that
shall apparently go unnamed I don't want
to do anything else besides the job I'm
doing but I'm struggling with the
current war on the media it seems like
the media in quotation marks is such an
undefined character what is the media am
i part of the media am i as culpable as
the makers of Drudge Report how can I
handle when friends or families blame
the media for how they received their
news and most of all how can I a fairly
low down on the food chain but still
with a platform to express my views to
others make a difference in a fairly
stubborn political bubble news and
newspapers this is new
whose G uns nope G and us Oh God Janus
is just guns
I mean what's a new it's like I'm gonna
animal it is exactly like it's not just
like some kinda animal it is some kind
of animal
I've found it itself kind of animal yeah
anyway news and newspapers great yeah I
mean grace the good news is that
hopefully you knew when you were getting
into this job what you were getting into
because people have hated the media
since time immemorial like there's been
a lack of trust in newspapers
since there were newspapers yeah it does
it feels a little like we had oh like a
brief moment of everybody was like kind
of on board with it and then and now
it's it's like moved back into the being
like everything is fake and and if a duh
I don't think people think everything is
fake I think people think that
everything is shaped right by us
and that they can't trust any facts but
I also think that's largely because
people don't and to an extent news media
organizations aren't doing a good job of
differentiating between reporting and
analysis yeah it's it has become very
clear to me that even I don't have a
really great grasp on that like I I know
that that I know the difference I know
what the difference is and I know that
like collecting and disseminating
information is extremely valuable and
without that there would be no
conversations worth having but I mostly
don't consume like here's what happened
I consume what does this thing that
happened mean yeah I think the great
risk Inc and we've talked about this a
lot is that in general a lot of times
when people are trying to contextualize
the news or present themselves as trying
to contextualize the news what they're
really trying to do is to frame the news
to meet your expectations or to fulfill
the confirmation bias of a particular
group or whatever like it's not really
about context deep down it's about
framing yeah and people like frames they
want to look at the world through the
frames that you know kind of confirm
what they already believe to be true
and so I understand why that stuff works
but it isn't news right but it is that
it is the thing that you can you get
views on and that like that's what we're
at we know that there's this this
problem where if we are looking at what
what we should be consuming is different
from what we want to consume and so and
when it comes down to like okay should I
read the Wikipedia page on this
controversial topic or should I read
what my like what my feed is throwing me
about like the take that it most makes
me feel good about the way that I feel
about the world and could most confirms
my worldview and my understanding of the
people who I like and don't like I'm
gonna go with that second thing because
reading a Wikipedia page is boring yeah
but also because going with the second
thing allows your mind to indulge
exciting and surreal conspiracy theories
and that feels good right like there's a
reason that everybody believes can spear
including me by the way believes
conspiracy theories that if they were
proven to be true would be great news
for them it's because like it's an
incredibly attractive thing it's like
gossip on the largest possible scale I
uh I mean we have this tension between
what is what is good for us and what
feels good in the moment not just when
it comes to news right like I have it
all the time when it comes to McDonald's
I think we live in a world of abundance
we live in a world of abundant
information or at least those of us who
are blessed to live it in the parts of
the world that are defined by abundance
we live in a world of abundant
information abundant food abundant this
abundant that where it's not about how
much stuff you can have because you can
have a lot of stuff you can acquire a
lot of combs relatively inexpensively
and and we I feel like we have to get
better as a species at understanding
that more is not always better and what
feels good right now is not always what
we actually want yeah so what would I
say to grace I would say we all
especially people in in media and
whatever that is and of course like
great thing about blaming the media is
that of course whenever you say it you
mean the media that you don't like and
so you could say it and yes so it
doesn't it's not about you it's about
people having opinions about something
that they saw but trying to find ways to
get information across that is both
accurate and is is new and is
contextualized and but also entertaining
and so it's like figuring out ways to do
that that's what's important and and
doing that without resorting to how can
I write a headline that sounds
misleading so that people will click on
it because I have gotten really
frustrated by this new trend of having
really great articles that have really
bad headlines because 90% of people only
read the headline and so 90% of people
come and come away with an inaccurate
point of view on the situation yeah so
don't do that
well I think it's hard and I think it's
complicated and I have to say that it's
very difficult to go against human
nature or the whims of the market forces
so let's do another question okay
sorry grace yeah I don't think we have
any good news on that front grace we
both feel a little discouraged this
question comes from Haneen who writes
dear green brothers my name is Haneen
and I'm a big fan of the pod in both you
guys so recently in our Arabic class we
were discussing a poem in which the poet
was praising a certain king saying that
he built his kingdom to reach higher
than Gemini and our teacher explained
this choice of constellation aside from
it rhyming with the rest of the poem
because quote Gemini is the highest
constellation I was taken aback by this
statement is that true can a
constellation even be high aren't they
all a bunch of stars floating in endless
space and also it made me think does a
poet or a writer have the right to mess
with science and actual facts just for
the sake of making their work sound
beautiful and poetic PS sorry for any
grammatical mistakes English is not my
native language as you may have probably
noticed I might die at any moment
Haneen first though I just want to say
that this this email has fewer
dramatical mistakes than almost any
email we've ever received yeah yep
you're quite good at that also excellent
sign-off excellent sign-off it's true
you might die at any moment
hey so I like this question Hank because
it kind of asked questions for both of
us does a writer have a right to mess
with science and actual facts just for
the sake of making your work sound
beautiful a question that I know a thing
or two about and and then secondarily is
there such a thing as a high
constellation well in terms of distance
from the earth all constellations are
well for the most part are made up of
stars that are very far away from each
other so they yo you're close to each
other in the plane of the sky but but
they are varying distances away there
are some exceptions to that where it
where some some star clusters in an
constellation are actually part of a
grouping in space but mostly that is not
the case but they are also you know so
that's certainly the higher like the
higher a star is like the further away
from it is for the most part that means
it's farther away from us and so the
really high constellations are the ones
that are made up of stars that you can't
even see wait no but I think our it's
not that like stars near the top of our
sky are necessarily further away than
stars near the bottom of our sky no well
and indeed a star like where a star is
in the sky changes all night long and
and also depending on where you are on
earth so they're there right yeah there
is no there is no star that is at the
top of the sky first of all because this
guy is a dome and so the top would just
be like whatever happens to be right
above you at the moment I guess because
it's not like what's on the north side
no its but that's that's gonna change
anyway like all that stuff moves around
moves around all all all night because
this is because the earth is spinning
around it is a matter of perspective
correct and then yes so I don't know if
there is I don't but I don't think about
constellations so I cannot tell you if
there's something particularly high
about Gemini maybe there's something you
nor can I tell you anything however I
can tell you that the stars in Orion's
belt there's a very visible
constellation from Indiana I don't know
visible it is in the rest of the world
the Orion the Hunter there's these three
stars that look like they're in a
complete like line and they're very
bright in the Indiana sky and they are
literally hundreds of light years apart
from each other like they are further
away from each other than they are from
us yeah it's so mind-blowing to think
that they look inches apart and they are
so so so far apart as nice
visualizations you can experience
there's actually a kind of game that
it's more of just like a simulator thing
where you can download this software and
you can like go around like you can go
from the earth and you can move off and
see what the sky looks like from other
places and it's very cool that sounds
cool we'll put a we'll put a link on the
patreon patreon comm slash dear Hank and
John and you don't have to pay to get
this yeah yeah all the things are free
but you can pay we won't get mad
the second question though I think is a
really interesting one because there are
times when I think it's okay to mess
with facts but you've gotta know that
you're messing with them so or that's my
theory anyway
I did this in The Fault in Our Stars
where I wanted there was a line I liked
that some infinities are bigger than
others which is true but the way that
hazel talks about that is untrue and I
liked the attention of that I think
looking back I would have made it clear
that hazel was wrong somehow because I
think a lot of people walked away from
that thinking that there are more
numbers between zero and two than there
are between zero and one which is not
true and I wish that I had not
accidentally misinformed a large swath
of you know like a generation of
American teenagers about infinite
cardinality but I did so no getting
around that I think in general like you
have to work with the world as you find
it as a writer and part of that is
trying
to be honest about science but there are
also times in my work and lots of people
would say this is a bad thing about them
where I've taken things that are true in
science and tried to apply them to other
things in life where they may or may not
be true like you know like the idea that
energy isn't created or destroyed well
that that is not an idea that you can
scientifically apply to the human spirit
uh-huh yes yeah I think that that is
that is a common thing that happens
where we try to appeal to the like that
you know the things that we know about
science the the realities of science and
we try to apply them to things that
don't aren't actually affected by them
but but in general if you like I I feel
like that if you like certainly it has
to be internally consistent so one of
the great things about writing is that
like you don't have to write inside of
our universe with our universes rules
like there are other universes you can
write inside of but if you're if your
stuff exists inside of this universe you
really called out if you're if you are
creating on a like a thing that does not
exist but if it's a if it's magical
realism do it do it up like that's one
of the great things about fiction is
that we can see it like we can imagine
universes that are different from ours
and sometimes those things are going to
be resonant in ways that are like beyond
just how you know it affects the story
and like you know beyond just creating a
cool world there's also truths that can
be told that way but it is also it can
be very dangerous tool because you if
you're trying to do more than like
create more than beauty if you're trying
to create ideas and you're appealing to
ideas that like you're creating truths
that aren't actually true then that's a
really good way to sell an ideology that
isn't accurate and and I like I often
see that in in in in discourse more than
in fiction where people are like well I
know that this particular example of
this of this thing is made up but it's
indicative of a law
your truth I know that like I know that
what I'm saying right now I understand
that I was caught lying or sighting
something that was fake and I didn't
realize was fake but it's indicative of
a broader truth and it resonates with
people because they see that that that
that the this is basically true even if
the all of the examples we can find are
not accurate
speak speaking of which we have another
question from Sarah who writes dear John
and Hank on my flight tonight the person
sitting next to me noticed I am
currently reading The Chronicles of
Narnia I told him I'd never read them as
a kid and thought I'd give them a try
now he said he loves CS lewis and
proceeded to discuss the books with me
at length at the end of our conversation
he asked if I'd ever read on Rand
because quote if I like The Chronicles
of Narnia I would really enjoy the
fountainhead especially if you've only
read two books is this true would you
consider enjoying The Chronicles of
Narnia a solid basis for someone to
enjoy the fountainhead Sarah no no Sarah
I would not you know John I've never
read The Fountainhead
I got 16 problems with this guy sitting
next to Sarah on the airplane number one
get a list about oh goodness
you never ever interrupt somebody when
they're reading a book to tell them that
you have also read that book the only
exception to this and it is a
questionable exception is if you have
written the book in question it is
sometimes only sometimes acceptable I
think to say fYI I wrote that book so
yeah I I did want to see someone reading
The Fault in Our Stars in a bookstore
and I was like nope not gonna do it
yeah I do it dude yes no and that's
probably the right call
I mean hey my brother wrote that book
look at me I would have been like no I
mean I might have walked out to them and
say it said like that's a good one you
should buy it
you know what I go into Barnes & Noble I
do go to your section I turn them facing
out cuz it's just just the spine you
don't not get in as much shelf real
estate so I get rearranged some stuff so
that so that your books can face out I
hope you appreciate that work that I'm I
do appreciate that but I also always
feel like it maybe hurt somebody else
who's probably a nice person but I do
appreciate it anyway I
well yeah you [ __ ] you shouldn't do
it but I don't laugh cuz it's my brother
the number two thing is if you like the
Chronicles of Narnia it does not the
mean that you will enjoy the
fountainhead all it means is that that
person has read like an extremely narrow
set of fiction I can probably name like
five other books that person has read
probably some Robert Heinlein Heinlein
however you pronounce his name
I bet he's read I bet he's read the Lord
of the Rings trilogy probably read the
War of the Rings trilogy I suspect he's
read 1984 but like not in a way that
really took it to heart
you've only been mmm Fahrenheit 451 I
don't know if you know this Hank Oh Lord
of the Flies I don't know if you know
this about me but I hate hate hate hate
hate The Fountainhead I hate it hate it
hate it hate it I hate I know a lot of
people listening out there right now
don't hate it and I'm sorry because I
probably am making you feel like not
great and I'm sorry I don't want to make
you feel that way but it's just I just
hate it I just yeah I I think I think
the world would be better if it didn't
exist and I think the ideas in it are a
vintage example of what you just
described where you create a fictional
world in which a bunch of things that
are not actually true are true and then
because people feel like it reflects
something true about their experience
that is based on the idea that they are
somehow special or unique and the world
is aligned against them but it's not
aligned against other people it's just a
goodbye but I was wrong yeah
we've got another question shot it comes
from Becky who asks dear green brothers
I'm a third thing I don't like in this
situation John can you skip the like the
middle the middle thirteen things and
skip straight to 16 yeah but I've
starting a spinoff podcast called issues
I have with the guy sitting next to
Sarah well that I'm also excited to hear
that this one is from Becky who asks
dear green brothers I'm a US citizen
working in Mexico for the year with an
NGO and I've recently come to my
attention that my Mexican colleagues
were taught and firmly believe that
there are five continents Africa America
Asia Europe and Oceania and I on the
other hand I and the other US citizens
in the office were taught and believed
read until recently that there were
seven continents Africa Asia Europe
North America Oceania and South America
although this was an earth shifting
discovery for me I can appreciate that
continents are that was only six that
was only six but I didn't say all of
them you didn't say oh but it's kind of
better that way because it points to how
made up continents are so just go on
although this was although this was an
earth shifting discovery for me I can
appreciate the continents are social
constructs and my question is this is
there a right social construct to teach
yes oh there is yes first off I think
it's crazy that we differentiate between
Europe and Asia when they are clearly
obviously in arguably one continent I
mean it's interesting that that the
Mexican colleagues also think that
Europe and Asia are separate separate
continents I think that there's really
there's really only one argument to be
made John in my opinion yeah there is
there is one continent no do you just
can there used to be one continent I
agree
but now there are two countries I am
willing to accept two because there are
two really big up but if you look from
the top all that stuff's really close
together yes but we don't look from the
top because nobody lives up at the top
because it's so cold I mean it's getting
warmer every year but it's still fairly
cold I'm just saying I just flew from
America to Europe
and I don't think I saw the ocean the
whole time I'm gonna just go ahead and
call BS on that one maybe it was a
cloudy day but you flew over the ocean I
promise there are flowe over some
limited swaths of ocean so the two
continents just to be clear the two
continents this is like my argument that
every everything is essentially a shade
of brown that's that's why I feel like
there's one cotton I mean I'm concerned
that I'm undermining my authority so
much that a bunch of people are gonna go
out and read The Fountainhead or
alternately that I hate The Fountainhead
so much that it's gonna make people want
to read it maybe I should just ignore it
because actually the opposite of love
Hank is not hate its apathy anyway hmm
anyway there are two continents there is
afro-eurasia which is obviously one
continent and then there is the Americas
which is obviously one continent now I
realize this leaves out a bunch of
places like Hawaii Australia New Zealand
those places are not there they just
don't count well no it's not that they
don't count do you have to be on a
continent no Greenland nobody argues
that Greenland is a continent but it is
a large landmass that contains people
Iceland is not a continent neither is
Australia / I mean I I ocean are things
because you want to include all the
people but let's you can't include all
the people because we're talking about
weird social constructs there's two
continents afro-eurasia Mae okay there's
three continents afro-eurasia
Oceania I'm backing down on Oceania
Oceania I don't even know how to say it
it's such a made-up idea that I don't
even know how to say the word I'm back
okay yes I'm back so yeah but there are
but let's establish are there people who
are not on continent yes yes Hawaiians
and astronauts I'm pretty sure actually
Hawaii is technically part of Oceania
ocean yeah it's just like it's all
inclusive of the oceans I think it might
include some I think it might include
Madagascar Oceania Madagascar Hawaii and
Greenland
well that's flawed Oceana yeah yeah
definitely Greenland is in Oceania I
don't think you'll find any
dreamin about that the question is are
the are the Caribbean islands in Oceania
like what about Bermuda Bermuda it's
like III went I've never been to Bermuda
but I was like I was thinking maybe it
would be fun to go to Bermuda I would
like to go on a beachy vacation and so I
was like looking on Google Maps all you
know just like south of Florida where
all the Caribbean islands are and I was
like man I cannot find Bermuda anywhere
here that's because it's nowhere near
there it's off like South Carolina yeah
it's up there where the Drina Triangle
is first off I have no I I mean I
thought the Bermuda Triangle was just
south of Jamaica nope it's up by Bermuda
I'm pretty sure they've been okay first
off just not to correct you Hank but the
Bermuda Triangle one point of it is in
Bermuda the other point is in South
Florida and the Third Point is in Puerto
Rico so in fact a number of Caribbean
islands are inside the Bermuda Triangle
I'm not as much of an idiot as you would
like to have me believe however Bermuda
itself is like basically it it's it's
basically one of like Maine's outer
islands I mean it is much closer to
Canada yeah it is to jog like when you
say Bermuda you're like oh yeah this has
got to be the but I mean I think it is
fairly warm and tropically because it's
in the middle of the ocean and it's
really far off the coast it's a weird
thing it it seems like one of the
locations that would have been mentioned
in the classic Beach Boys song Kokomo
indeed Bermuda is the first one in the
list oh it is it is mentioned Bermuda
Jamaica girl I want to take you I
believe is there no no no that I just
violet car no it's not does its Bermuda
Bahama come on pretty mama is that's the
second the second okay
there's no no it's it begins or ulla
Jamaica do I want to take you to Bermuda
Bermuda is third it's in the second
standard key largo Montego baby why
don't we go
is there really a place off the Florida
Keys called Kokomo because there's a
place about 40 minutes north of me
called Kokomo Indiana and I would not
describe it as tropical
I don't think that there is a real place
called Kokomo in in the there is a there
is a sand sandals que is a privately
owned island in in Jamaica that was
formerly called Kokomo island but I
think after the song there's a there's a
you think so Inc I think I'm gonna check
formerly called Kokomo island was
originally named after the the song that
was not written by the Beach Boys just
performed by them the inspiration for
the song was a poolside bar in Isla
Mirada in the Florida Keys SoCo who
wrote the song uh John Phillips Mike
Love Terry Melcher and Scott my club is
in the beach Michael of is in the Beach
Boys okay for the record
well what about Terry meadow no is John
Phillips of uh isn't John Phillips in
like Peter Paul and Mary or something
probably not in Peter Paul and Mary
since he's not either fall or Barrow he
was he was in the Beach Boys and all
said the Mamas and the Papas the Mamas
and the Papas I was close okay I was
close all right but he was he was just
associated with the Beach Boys according
to this Wikipedia page his name is not
Ryan so I don't know why I'm on his
Wikipedia page right now yeah anyway the
the the best part about this whole bit
Hank is that literally nobody who
listens to this podcast remembers the
Beach Boys song Kokomo except for you
and me because it came out in 1989 so
like and also I don't think it was that
big of a hit I think our parents just
liked it a lot so sorry I wasn't
everyone who's listening
I cannot first of all I cannot believe
that it came out in 1989 I always
assumed that it was much earlier than
that because most of the Beach Boys
stuff was much earlier than that second
it was me and my girlfriend in third
grade it was our song was it really it
was that's pretty cute yeah I guess
that's pretty cute you know my first
song my first song with a girl was that
Tiffany song I think we're alone now
well I think we're all sort of inal oh
yeah probably not yeah I know that was a
cover
I own that on vinyl my first two vinyl
records were Michael Jackson's Thriller
which is a properly good album and
Tiffany's I think we're alone
which does not hold up that well I do
remember you owning that record John is
not making this up my do you remember
what my first vinyl was John
i 100% know what your first vinyl was I
don't know if you know but I'm a hundred
percent positive do you want to say it
at the same time sure okay
three two one the Shepherd problem oh
you're right it probably was the Chuckie
Cheese album it was 100 percent Chuckie
Cheese 45 that played like happy
birthday on one side it might have even
been Showbiz Pizza it played happy
birthday on one side and but it wasn't
the usual happy birthday song it was
dead it did it did it I think it's your
birthday
yeah yeah that one uh-huh I think it's
your birthday is that what they say is
that I was I was thinking that it was
the supergirls album but that was that
was later which was like a collection of
a bunch of like girl rock bands from the
60s and 70s on to to to LPS yeah now
it's actually pretty good it was good
egg pop pop I got it for me off the
time-life Time Life subscription it's
quick quick quick follow-up question
what question is really for people
really for people who were born
significantly before 1980 like we've
really made this we've we've limited our
the scope of our audience dramatically
with this last conversation but there is
one continent and Kokomo is not on it
God the continents oh my god oh my god I
wish like I wish I could get a diagram
of the series of sentences that led to
this moment well work through it do you
do you want to move on or can we just
admit that that continents are a made-up
idea and before we move on I just have
to quickly say that today's podcast is
brought to you by sandals sandals
secretly sponsoring this podcast can we
maybe get three hundred and seventy
eight free sandals days Hank
no thank you honest I do not
I do not have the time or interest for
any sandals - is this podcast is also
brought to you by the media the media do
you don't like us for some reason Hank
I'm just gonna stop you right there and
say that I love a good all-inclusive
vacation and I do not like you talking
smack about them and I suspect when your
kids get older you'll like it too
and of course today's podcast is also
brought to you by Oceania Oceania a word
that John is trying to learn how to
pronounce and finally this podcast is
brought to you by subpar combs they're
not very good but they were free yeah
alright John I got one more question
before I go it's about it's about me
yeah I hope that's okay sure this
question comes from Lily who asks Hank
what are amber lamps I love your song
amber lamps but it's it's so relaxing
but I had absolutely no clue what it was
about so I looked up what our amber
lamps and I found a very odd meme did
you write an entire song about a meme
the mean was created in 2010 so it's
entirely possible that you're a hell of
Ellen Hardcastle which came out in 2011
could have a song about a mean would
like an answer yep
that's all I gotta say Attis that is
what yep yep it is it's a nice calm
soothing song that is about a meme yeah
Hank wrote a song about a meme it's not
it's not even really his first song
about a meme I would say it's now it's
it's one of the lesser-known memes and
it's also one of things that's for known
songs it is yeah I mean honestly I was
finishing that album and I was like I
really feel like there should be one
more song in this album and I was like
like okay well I guess if something
strikes me and then it struck me and I
recorded it and I put it on there and I
did it all in an afternoon by myself so
it's it's it's a bit of a departure on
that album it's like suddenly we're what
are we doing now but yeah it's about a
meme alright speaking of what are we
doing now it's time for the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon
thank you want to go first or deal me to
go first oh the news from Mars it's bad
news from Mars John hmmm so you'll
remember that Donald Trump our president
of my country said that he wanted he
would like to see and he was was rooting
for and was excited about getting
astronauts on Mars during quote during
my first tour term or at worst during my
second term sir NASA has responded
they're not gonna do that yeah they have
said the White House asked us to look at
the plan that we have today and see if
we can keep going on that current plan
said the Acting Administrator Robert
Robert Lightfoot who is what an amazing
name for an administrator of NASA they
have asked us they have not they have
not asked us to go to Mars by 2024
terrible news for me John
but it's confirmed that Donald Trump was
like all right jump over this 50 foot
high building and NASA was like can we
have like I don't know a trillion
dollars and they were like that's not
how this works and they're like well no
we can't we cannot unaided jump over a
50 foot tall building yeah I mean that's
not a huge surprise Hank that Donald
Trump said that he was going to be able
to do something that he's struggling to
to execute it's kind of been a theme of
the presidency so far the news from AFC
Wimbledon well I think it's it's the
silly season as they call it it's the
off season we've got to long brutal
actually more like three long brutal a
horrible months of this however the
silly season kicked off in earnest
earlier today Hank when a news report
came out in which Wimbledon manager Neil
Ardley said that he quote might have to
do some wheeling and dealing in order to
improve the squad not a lot of money at
AFC Wimbledon it's not a particularly
well-funded team owned by its fans as I
might have mentioned a few times
not owned by some billionaire so it's
gonna be mm-hmm difficult to improve the
squad but it's obviously also necessary
to improve the squad due to the lack of
a goal of the month in April but due to
no goals so that might mean some selling
might mean some players will get sold
that is at least the takeaway that a lot
of people on Twitter have is that
players might need to get sold in order
for other players to be bought which
would be a shame because I really like
the current AFC Wimbledon squad but I'll
tell you what I also like staying in
Ligue 1 ah
yes me too you weren't listening but
that's ok I'm not mad at you hey what
did we learn today
oh we learned that Gemini is so high
it's so high in the sky
we learned that Bermuda Jamaica
Madagascar Australia New Zealand
Greenland and Antarctica are all in the
same continent of Oceania we also
learned that Hank John don't ask us
about the fountainhead yeah just don't
bring it up and lastly we learned that
Hanks first album was a 45 from either
Chuckie Cheese or show his pizza it was
definitely Showbiz Pizza because we
didn't have a Chuckie Cheese back then
John it was all showing up in different
times guys it was hard out there that's
right and we listened we listened to the
Beach Boys later hits all right it's
time for us to go record our weekly
podcast this week in Ryan's which you
can get over at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John don't feel obligated
you're not missing much but if you want
to you can sign up for it we appreciate
it and it helps us fun complexly shows
like scishow and crash course and the
art assignment and sexplanations and
lots of other stuff so thanks everybody
who donates through the patreon thang
it's thanks to all of you for listening
and I think Hank is gonna read the
credits now yes this podcast is edited
by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
our social media manager is Victoria bon
giorno our music is by the great
gunnarolla
can email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com we're on Twitter at Hank green
and at John Green we love to see your
tweets and as they say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]